[Music]
[Music]
well hello you must be the new pool boy
your rod looks so shiny and smooth long
hard come on in pool boy
pool boy this is I love you to clean it
because it's but I'm gonna be laying
here getting some Sun it's gonna make me
look bronzing great thank you
[Music]
oh boy I don't want my bunghole to burn
can you put some suntan lotion on the
ring use the skimmer I think it says Bob
does it say bog well why don't you Bob
for apples
Amy asked me Kevin Smith Jim you've got
to come see our brand new movie Jay and
Silent Bob reboot when can they see it
take it seed on October 15th and 17
that's right Fatima Benton's having
sneak preview screenings man on the 17th
you can watch Jay and Silent Bob strike
back and Jay and Silent Bob reboot back
to back on the 15th is the big intro and
lots of extras afterwards what are you
waiting for you've waited long enough to
see a 17 years back on the big screen
come see us man fathom events sneak
preview screenings for more information
go to fathom events dot-com